[Music]
we're talking to ryan in greenville
south carolina so ryan um just to recap
for folks who are just joining us
you qualify for the student loan
forgiveness program you and your wife
are have some student loan debt you've
got some a little kid you don't feel
like it's right
you got some kids
you've come up with with
uh your value system says i don't want
to take this money i qualify for it i
can have it i don't want it and people
are giving you advice you should do it
you're a taxpayer you deserve this all
whatever
so is that about right
that's right no kids yet though okay no
no kids so uh
why do you have this value why do you
think this why do you think that you
don't feel like you can take it
well i mean the principle on the micro
scale applied to ourselves right so
i signed something i made a commitment
to it right so i should honor my word
and keep that commitment and also i
have the sphere of influence of folks
around me that have done the same and
they made it through and they paid it
off and it was such a big boost in their
life and their marriage it strengthened
their marriage to strengthen their i
guess dignity dignity and
um i feel like i want to be part of that
crowd but i'm also like am i being proud
am i being a little too proud about this
or do these older folks that say i
should take advantage of it do they have
a point is it something it's just
strange like a strange time to live
where things like government help is
kind of
taking precedence and i don't know like
is it sacrificing our own
accountability and i don't know you see
the consequences on the individual
scales there's got to be global
consequences
no question um our whole system is built
on um that's future us problem
we'll let them deal with that later
right that's that's the whole system can
we punt this thing right
um
george before i i'd love to get your
thoughts on we're talking about this off
here a little bit um
i find it helpful in these moments ryan
to back out of the current moment in the
politics of it all
this is this is the coven vaccine this
is um should i work at this place this
is should i take student loan
forgiveness
these things get so hot and they get so
political and it clouds your judgment
and so i just want to back out and say
this isn't a strange time for people to
be faced with various values questions
and i'm going to answer that question
on its merits and i'm not i'm not going
to get involved in the fray and there's
something inside of you that says
i don't feel right about it george we
think i think if you're going to lose
sleep overtaking it don't do it and if
it's going to propel your financial
journey that's fine too but my issue is
kind of feeling like you're on a high
horse and you're better than the folks
who took it right and you're going well
i
i my value say it's a bad thing i pay
into social security i don't want to do
it but am i going to take it when i
retire sure
i paid into it stimulus check we got
stimulus checks all right i'll take it
i'm not going to go like i'm going to
refund this back to the government
because i don't believe in stimulus
checks so i just don't think it's a i
disagree with the entire premise of it
but i also don't have a strong enough
moral compass to go absolutely not and
you bring up something important ryan
let me tell you how i personally deal
with these things right so i take the
politics out of it and then i make my
decision
and then i tell no
one because if i feel like i have to
announce my values my personal values
and my personal choices to the world
then it's i'm i'm virtue signaling i'm
not sticking by a principle i'm doing
something so that i can make an
announcement about it instead of this is
a personal value like when people uh
take social media fast and they have a
big post about why they're taking it
fast because they're better than all of
us for getting off social media like
that john
like that so ryan
if if man if your value say don't take
it don't take it and don't lose a second
of sleep over it and here's the thing
you don't have to you don't have to
you're going to ask 40 different people
you're going to get 40 different answers
right right so
sit with your wife and you'll make this
decision on your own that one that you
can sleep with and then let that be your
decision and let this be practice for
future
values based decisions you're going to
have to make in the future
and let them be yours and yours alone i
think one of the challenges we've run
into is we have to make hard decisions
in our lives and then now we have a
platform to tell everybody about them
and it quickly divides up the world and
people stop being neighbors and they
stop being
parents on this on a softball league or
parents sit on the sidelines of a kid's
dance recital and it becomes
you versus me and man stick by your
values love them be good about it and
then go on with your day does that sound
fair
that sounds fair cool man well
congratulations for even having even
thinking about it right well another
piece of this he mentioned is you know
the character
uh that you develop by sacrificing and
paying off debt i think he's already
experienced that i don't think he's
gonna miss out on it by getting 10k
forgiven right and so for that piece i
say yes it absolutely changes your
character and how you look at money when
you had to pay it off and i'm happy for
those people there's amazing personal
growth there he's already experienced
that i don't think he's going to revert
back to i'm just going to wait on
everyone to fix my life ryan he's
already done this stuff right and i
think the key is whether you take it or
whether you don't
don't wear it as a badge of this just
elevated me above you exactly personal
choice you made cool let's move on with
our day right i love that thanks for the
call um ryan that's helpful for folks